you talk about uh disposition being more
important than position yeah what you
mean by that well listen I know some
billionaires that are pretty miserable
and I know some guys with uh boring
office jobs that very happy I think your
disposition is it's very difficult to
change but it's often easier than
changing the world you know you are
you're in your head on your own an awful
lot of the time no matter how connected
you are no matter how great your family
you're you you are you and you know the
acceptance of that
and the way that you see the world the
rose tinted glasses of looking at the
world looking for jokes is pretty
tremendous I think the thing that makes
a difference to people on disposition is
um in the most part it's gratitude can
kind of move the dial that's the thing
that seems to make a difference because
it's that thing of like if you're if
you're in a bad mood all the time you're
not in a bad mood you're an
[__] it's the truth of it so it's go
how are you most of the time the how you
treat a waiter or a waitress or how you
react when you get a speeding ticket or
any of those little things that because
life is going to throw lots of that
stuff at you how do you react to it h
how how are you in the world what's your
is it a sunny disposition or are you
kind of you know are you are you are you
boring well you've been through bouts of
depression as as I have I I actually
thought throughout all of my 20s that I
was depressed I thought that that was
the texture of my mind I thought it was
locked in like the worst weed trip that
you've ever had this is me for the rest
of my life
okay so I'm interested in conflated
words and often think depression is
conflated with sadness and sadness is
much more um difficult to admit and it's
much more uh there's more of a stigma
around being I'm depressed it's kind
there's a c certain glamour to being
depressed Loof it's sort of this
mysterious thing it's pathologized it
suggests depth yeah well sadness is just
well you sad [__] you're sad what do you
do you got a surface level life you run
clubs sure having a nice time whatever
but it's it's surface level so that
Depression was maybe sadness but I think
if it's environmental if you could
change it if it's not to do with the
serotonin levels in your head and a
cical EMB barrance then it's if you can
do something about it it's sadness so
assuming it's sadness and that you can
do something about it I mean listen it's
people with real mental health problems
and my heart goes out to them but for a
lot of people it's just there it's
circumstantial but you went through
periods of acute sadness or depression
however you want
to label it and yet you've managed to
get yourself to a stage largely
anxiety's been the big is really my um
drug of choice yeah and anxiety I
think's got I think there's a gift in
there I think the gratitude that I have
for anxiety is it's the flip side of
creativity correct that your mind is
racing and sometimes you're trying to
solve a problem in the future because
you don't have anything to do now it's
why people talk about you know I'm so
happy when I exit exercise because
you're giving yourself a problem right
now and your mind is dealing with
whatever lifting that up and putting it
down yeah you put 120 kilos on a on a
bar you're not thinking about much else
other than I really need to get this off
me yeah that that thing of like that
simple thing of going you probably don't
have enough to do if you're anxious
about silly things in the future or the
um I mean I'm I get very tied up
with counterfactuals and wondering about
what might have been and what should
I've
done and you know it kind of links to me
to that weird thing of like no one's
scared of falling off a cliff we're
worried about
jumping there's a there's there's kind
of a weird thing of going what if I'd
done something different what if I'd
told you that that you've heard that
Douglas Murray thing about in life we
must choose our regrets right yeah I
mean you can have anything you can't
have everything
yeah yeah that uh what could have been
we can't split split test life we can't
go back yeah and give this another crack
I tell you for a guy with a sunny
disposition it's a very serious
conversation isn't it yeah I quite like
this I feel this is very I feel like in
the moment to Calla it feels very
revealing to have this conversation
because it doesn't feel unlike the
conversation we had at dinner the other
day but it is that thing if you go it's
kind of showing more of yourself than
you you know normally it's just dick
Jokes wait until people see you haven't
got pants on underneath them uh cut to
the
White it needs to be very wide um yeah I
so I'm interested in
this if anxiety is your malady your
mental malady of choice yeah and yet
you've managed to get yourself to
a state where you are in a sunny
disposition at least some nonzero amount
of the
time yeah sorry just to go back to
because I'm still thinking about
disposition position because people
climb to a position and they think
happiness is going to live there and I
think you'd be better served trying to
make yourself happy and then worrying
about where you're
going I think your happiness your
emotional well-being working on that
first seems to be a very sensible thing
because it doesn't live down the road it
doesn't live you know you put a million
dollars in the bank it won't it won't
make you less
insecure that kind of scarcity mindset
is kind of poison is that a lesson that
can be learned without going and seeing
the top of the mountain yourself because
there will be a lot of people that could
say Jimmy easy for you to say about Fame
isn't going to fix your problems money
isn't going to fix your problems you've
achieved both well fame fame I think has
replaced heaven in a secular
World Fame is the land of milk and honey
where everything is okay and you're
looked after and it's perfect and I'm
not knocking it i' love being famous but
it's not the be all and end all and
actually again you can you can kind of
split test that cuz I can go to a
country where I'm not known not many but
there's a
few you talk about why trajectory is so
important as well and I think that this
ties in here it's all people see isn't
it like people aren't interested in how
you know if you're playing 250 shows a
year like I've been doing that for years
it's not exciting it's not news it's
news when people arrive and they're new
so when something you know in I think
fil and TV and comedy and kind of
entertainment it's it's like it's all
about where were they last year where
are they this year just
maintaining no one seems to care
although Comics aren't entertainers in
the true sense the true definition of an
Entertainer is if you don't like me I
don't like
me oh that's interesting you've that's a
real Entertainer you've outsourced your
self worth to the crowd of course that's
what an Entertainer is and there's I
know guys that are entertainers friend
said that to me and it was like oh man
that is that is your journey good luck
that's hard comedians desperately want
to be loved but entirely on their own
terms it's a lovely Paradox every single
morning for over 3 years now I have
started my day the exact same way which
is with element in water element
contains a science-backed electrolyte
ratio of sodium potassium and magnesium
and it is the best hydration drink that
I've ever found it tastes fantastic it's
super refreshing orange is just the most
OP flavor in the world it's absolutely
phenomenal and it helps to play a
critical role in reducing muscle cramps
and fatigue it regulates your appetite
it optimizes brain health and it helps
curb Cravings they're also the exclusive
hydration partner to Team USA
weightlifting and relied on by tons of
Olympic athletes and everyday High
performers all around the world also
there is a nobs no questions asked
refund policy where you can buy a box
completely risk-free and if you do not
like it for any reason they will give
you a refund during an unlimited
duration and you don't even need to
return the box that's how confident they
are that you love it ele are giving away
a free sample pack of all eight flavors
with your first box if you go to the
link in the description box below or
drink LM andt.com
MW that's drink LM nt.com
MW thank you very much for tuning in if
you enjoyed that clip with Jimmy press
here for the fulllength 2 and 1 half
hour podcast episode you don't want to
miss it go
on